[Musique]
Simone Veil
seul l'espoir apaise la douleur
[Musique]
un podcast original produit par Lina
écrit par les avenstein avec le concours
de Dominique Missika
[Musique]
le 18 janvier 1945 devant l'avancée de
l'armée rouge les Allemands évacuent le
camp de beaubreak
Simone Veil sa mère et sa soeur sont
emmenés dans une marche de la mort vers
les Candas puis de glaive
en les pousse ensuite dans un train qui
les achemine dans des conditions
infernales vers le camp de Dora et enfin
celui de bergenbelsen elles y arrivent
toutes les trois le 30 janvier
le camp est ravagé par le typhus la mère
de Simone en meurt sous ses yeux alors
que sa sœur est tout juste sauvée par
l'arrivée des Alliés le 15 avril
on croit parfois à tort que le retour
des rescapés marque la fin de l'enfer
pour Simone Veil c'est le moment
terrible du deuil de ceux qui ne
reviennent pas c'est le silence pesant
qu'on impose alors au rescapés
viendront ensuite le temps de l'amour
puis la construction d'une famille et de
la carrière politique que nous
connaissons la douleur ne la quittera
jamais mais elle devient la source de
son ultime détermination témoigner et
transmettre
[Musique]
Simone Veil seul l'espoir apaise la
douleur
dernier épisode
le retour et la vie après
[Musique]
on a été libéré le 17 avril si je me
souviens bien quand je suis jamais
exactement et on est reparti
on est rentré le 23 mai donc le 18 mai
c'est-à-dire qu'on était pas du tout
pressé de nous faire rentrer en réalité
on nous a pas soigné du tout
on n'a pas eu du tout un régime adapté
ma sœur a pu manger à peu près
convenablement des choses qu'elle puisse
manger grâce aux soldats français qui
ont appris notamment il y avait des
officiers qui étaient à Lubec qui sont
venus parce qu'ils savaient qu'il y
avait des femmes enfin c'était les
officiers Juifs qui étaient
à Lübeck et en présence et qui sachant
qu'il y avait des femmes juives qui
étaient là qui sont venus et des soldats
un n'en fait que passer mais il y a des
soldats français dans ce salades qui
étaient juste à côté et qui sont venus
nous voir plusieurs fois et il y avait
notamment un jeune médecin qui voulait
absolument rester pour nous soigner il
n'a pas eu l'autorisation il a dû
repartir assez rapidement parce que son
entrée en avion mais j'avais apporté des
cigarettes on n'avait pas du tout envie
de fumer mais les cigarettes ça m'a
permis de faire des achats c'est à dire
que je sortais du temps sous les
barbelés parce qu'on avait absolument
pas le droit de sortir on était
complètement fermés là on était pas dans
les casernes de SS en ce moment là
c'est son roi qu'on avait déménagé donc
je suis sortie pour aller dans les
fermes et je faisais du troc avec les
cigarettes et c'est comme ça que j'avais
rapporté les pommes de terre du lait
pour ma sœur qu'elle a pu sauver parce
que son chat il n'avait que les rations
de l'armée
on est resté puis on est rentré mais
non
on sait pas beaucoup occupé de nous
les Anglais c'est encore la guerre les
Anglais
bon j'étais en guerre ils ont fait ce
qu'ils ont pu
les Français qui savaient qu'il y avait
tout de même pas mal le français
puisqu'il y avait un officier de liaison
mais l'officier de liaison
il a été là pour
pour faire les papiers
vous avez l'impression qu'on s'est mis
occupé des prisonniers de guerre ah oui
d'abord ils sont rentrés très vite eux
ont eu des avions nous on est rentré en
camion sauf la dernière étape on est on
a fait cinq jours de camion entassé plus
ou moins debout et mal installé ou assis
dans le fond du camion et simplement moi
je à chaque étape je négociais pour que
ma sœur soit à côté du chauffeur les
chansons on était c'était épouvantable
et conditions et la dernière étape a été
la dernière étape a été en train et ma
soeur a été à ce moment-là dans un
wagon sanitaire enfin bien jusqu'à Paris
si on est passé de partie de la
frontière des Pays-Bas passer par
Valenciennes et on est arrivé à Paris
mais sur ça c'était pour autant les
jours de séjour de camion c'était
horrible
on n'a pas eu une fois en dehors de
cette fille les gens on n'a pas eu une
fois une visite rien du tout
et non mais en revanche vraiment les les
soldats qui avaient été en captivité
450 ils ont été formidables pour nous
mais c'était comme ça au retour parce
qu'on retourne dans les Juifs étaient
pas organisés les communistes étaient
avec la rue le rond les rues de gouvain
Villiers il y avait la FND hier l'autre
il avait fait des RP nous il y avait
rien alors on a été certainement été rue
Leroux moi j'ai mis les pieds une fois
je me suis dit que
c'était le cas ma sœur comme moi
d'ailleurs nous on avait la chance
d'avoir mes enquêtante qui était rentré
à Paris
mais là le drame que leur fils a été tué
juste avant et puis
quand on allait venir
il y avait indispensaire même plusieurs
années plus tard pour avoir pour pouvoir
faire un examen pour un dossier médical
on vous renvoyait on veut traitement
quasi en disant non ici c'est les
résistants et quand on a les rues Leroux
c'était pareil où il fallait prendre la
part de la carte du parti
et oui
il y en a encore quelques uns qui ont
survécu
ouais c'est pas généralisé mais on
pouvait entendre ça donc on préférait
moi une fois pour toute je préférais
pendant longtemps maintenant mon numéro
je suis brune et je vois pas
pratiquement
donc à votre retour votre sœur Madeleine
est en très mauvais état très malade
elle est très malade et je pense qu'elle
était même plus malade que je ne pensais
voilà il y avait une chose
je lui avais dit de pas se faire raser
les cheveux elle a fini par le faire
elle avait eu des croûtes terribles sur
la tête je peux est-ce que c'était là
aussi les poux qu'il avait mangé après
je sais pas des croûtes épouvanta et je
lui avais dit écoute attends on va être
libéré on va être libéré je me souviens
les 15 derniers jours je lui dis ne te
rase pas les cheveux tu regretteras et
puis la petite raser ses cheveux quand
même en dehors de ça il était très très
maigre elle était très malade maisons
qui tente était médecin tous les deux
ils ont beaucoup hésité à la faire
hospitaliser finalement ils l'ont soigné
chez eux et bien soigné
enfin ça a été long parce que quand je
suis parti moi je suis allé en Suisse au
mois d'août elle était encore assez
malade enfin
moi je me suis je prends même pas rendu
compte à quel point elle était malade on
mange ma sœur qui avait été alors
quand nous avions été arrêtés tous on a
reçu ensuite que papa avait été arrêté
aussi par des gens qu'on voit
postérieurs mais on se disait mais au
moins
on pensait que comme c'était peu de
temps dans la libération tout ça on
s'est dit que elle qu'on la retrouverait
qu'elle serait pas déportés et le jour
tiens pour moi ça a été je crois que
c'est la seule fois où j'ai vraiment
craqué pleurer tout ça on peut même plus
envie de pleurer
c'est le dernier jour on avait dernier
jour de camion
on est à la frontière alors là c'est un
oeil un très grand centre de tri de où
il y avait à la fois des prisonniers des
déportés des devenant un peu de partout
quel est tous les trains qui ensuite
partaient vers
les Pays-Bas donc c'est un gros son il y
avait un espèce de chemin de terre qui
menait jusqu'au train qui était là
jusqu'à la voie ferrée c'est toujours
prêt d'avoir cette je sais pas peut-être
de 300 mètres même pas de la voie ferrée
qui a été installée ce centre de liaison
puis je vois quelqu'un que j'avais connu
avant
Kim bio j'ai vu ta sœur de Nice
s'aperçoit que je savais pas du tout que
ma sœur avait été déportée alors je me
tromper j'ai confondu avec quelqu'un
d'autre c'est une autre etc donc j'ai
plus rien tirer d'elle enfin il
suffisamment pour que je sois sûr que
c'était
c'est ma soeur bon comme à ce moment-là
beaucoup de bruit avec couru carensuk on
avait exterminé tout le monde qui est
parti enfin on savait plus rien sur les
datant à l'autre les derniers temps
c'est vrai qu'il y a eu tout de même
énormément de gens qui sont soit sur les
routes soit fusillés soit
j'ai rejoint ma soeur qui était déjà
dans ce train sur wagon sanitaire puis
elle a pas compris mais qu'est-ce que tu
as dans cet état etc je
dis écoute je peux pas la le cacher de
Nice a dû être déporté aussi et je
raconte c'est une calmer
jusqu'à notre arrivée au Lutetia on
était heureusement elle avait été libéré
très tôt était rentré par la Suisse elle
était amateurson était rentrée par la
Suisse a été rentable
ça a été
au moins passer dans l'Oise
et vous avez cherché et attendu le
retour de votre frère
on a espéré très longtemps parce que
c'était en plus qui compliquait beaucoup
c'était qu'on savait qu'ils étaient
partis
n'ont pas
enfin dans les paysages enfin je savais
pas que vous exactement on va en tout
cas par ici en France qui n'avait pas
été à Auschwitz et on parlait des pays
baltes j'ai retrouvé un truc mais plus
anciens des Pays-Bas mais on n'a jamais
rien enfin on sait
notre Père et votre frère c'est qu'ils
ont été déportés après ensemble
les fiches de départ mais on ne sait
même pas ceux qui ont été à taona
souvent neuf ou ceux qui ont été à
Tallinn où il y avait un Estonie où il y
en a qui ont travaillé sur un aéroport
sur les 850 je crois ou 900 je crois
qu'il y en a une vingtaine qui sont
rentrés
et dont la plupart ne savent pas chaude
alors il y a maintenant le père des bois
qui travaille dans cette région sur
défauts etc qui pensent que peut-être
s'il a fait fait venir ces français
c'était pour justement
retrouver tous les gens qui avaient
terrifi retrouver des gens qui avaient
été enfouis dans les fosses pour que ce
soit les truites et être même leur tour
c'est un
de Fort Neuf et on est question dans le
Livre noir du Rainbow de ces Français
qui ont été dans ce port neuf mais
n'en dit rien non plus
[Musique]
la Libération
qui a été attendu pendant toute la paire
de déportation a-t-elle été votre tour à
Paris le bonheur escompté
bonheur c'est pas le bon mot mais non
pas du tout
beaucoup de difficultés à vivre
longtemps
non pas du tout envie de d'abord parce
qu'on se sent complètement déplacé
sont déplacés même gauche en plus bon
moi j'avais jamais vécu à Paris j'étais
quoi une petite lycéenne pas encore
étudiante vivant dans un milieu
provincial et tout d'un coup on est
projeté bon j'avais tout de même je suis
assez vite qu'il avait été reçu au chaud
si j'avais toujours dit ça jamais je
repasserai mon Bashung on ne ferai pas
d'études en même temps j'avais envie de
faire des études parce que maman nous
avait tellement élevé dans l'idée que
les femmes devaient avoir un métier un
vrai métier que c'était pour moi très
important enfin c'était
et j'avais toujours dit j'avais envie de
faire du droit je voulais être avocate
donc
au mois de septembre je m'en suis occupé
de m'inscrire
mais le mois de juillet
je sais pas je sais même pas ce que je
fais
je vois pas mal ma sœur Denis on va
jouer à mes sœurs je connais
pratiquement personne à Paris quelques
camarades pas beaucoup ils sont pas
rentrés je sais pas où ils sont j'ai pas
encore leur adresse un petit peu pas
beaucoup je vais voir mes amis de danse
si sûrement à ce moment là
plusieurs fois mais faut pas dire ce que
je fais pas grand chose
il leur avait raconté à votre tour ce
que vous aviez vécu
avec ma tante oui j'en ai beaucoup parlé
en même temps bon maison que les tentes
ils ont été très très généreux nous on a
plus rien non plus rien n'a rien
retourner mes parents ma sœur m'avait
dit mais si je sais pas comment ils ont
vécu trois mois de plus ils avaient plus
du tout d'argent ils avaient tout épuisé
il y avait rien
et en plus alors mon mari enfin mon
fiancé d'abord a été très bien très bien
accueilli
moi je me suis inscrite à Sciences Po et
au droit c'est comme ça que je l'ai
rencontré
et voilà je suis rentré
puis à ce moment-là je me suis dit bon
qu'est-ce que je vais faire et c'est à
ce moment-là que je alors pour le droit
je me suis renseigné il y avait des
sessions spéciales alors on a pu passer
deux années de droit en un an enfin
c'était assez généreusement et bien
organisé
et puis en même temps la pour science
peau ça a été m'inscrit pour m'inscrire
à Sciences Po puisque j'avais eu envie
qui venait c'était en fait sur ce pauvre
venait de se transformer en acier et
toute politique je suis allé d'ailleurs
très bien accueilli et on m'a dit mais
les femmes les jeunes femmes
les jeunes femmes et un examen l'examen
est déjà passé était en juillet et puis
là oui mais enfin si jamais il pouvait
pas l'imposer parce qu'il n'avait pas
pour les garçons ce qui est maintenant
serait absolument inaccepte enfin tout à
fait illégal alors c'est pourquoi on m'a
dit parce que les femmes elles
conscience peau pour se marier c'est pas
mon cas et c'était le cas pourtant alors
ils m'ont dispensé de passer le concours
cet examen plutôt
et il y avait une assez bonne idée ou
peut-être parce que c'était constitut
tardivement ils ont fait une conférence
spéciale on s'est retrouvé tous les gens
qui a un peu des situations assez
particulières au fond c'est assez bien
parce qu'on a eu un mètre de conférence
qui avait été lui-même un grand
résistant qui était très très ouvert et
c'était assez bien parce qu'on avait
tous eu des parcours un peu
difficiles certains étaient anciens
prisonniers sur des portes et aussi un
déportés je devais être la seule mais
qui avait pas pu qui était pas en France
il y avait
alors j'apparaissais tout un peu à
Sciences Po comme un objet non identifié
avec
l'envie de travailler et pas du tout si
j'allais si je sortais le soir sortie
très peu mais c'était vraiment pour me
forcer à sortir mais sans aucun plaisir
aucun goût perdu tout à fait dans ce
milieu
me souviens comme ça alors un peu plus
tard même si c'est un camarade
[Musique]
alors qui était après quand je me suis
fiancé qui était un gamin de
la même promotion que
la même
conférence que mon fiancé je t'ai invité
chez lui j'étais tout d'un coup
tellement perdu que il habitait
boulevard Suchet il y avait des grands
rideaux et je m'étais caché dans les
rideaux pour ne pas avoir à parler qui
que ce soit bon petit à petit
nous on l'a vu était très difficile
votre fiancée était juif
c'était important pour vous
j'aurais pas pu à ce moment là
vous poser quelqu'un qui soit pas juif
parce qu'il y avait trop de choses à
comprendre à assumer plus tard oui j'en
faisais pas du tout une question de
principe je parle religieuse j'ai pas
mais à ce moment-là je crois qu'au fond
j'ai retrouvé ma famille
et pour mardi gras par faire du ski et
avec un copain il me dit enfin bon on
pourrait aller faire du ski je dis bon
j'accepte d'aller faire du ski c'était
près au dessus de Grenoble et
un mari ça va m'y habitait Grenoble ils
étaient enfin en fait ils étaient leurs
reins la région de Nancy et ça avait été
réfugié pendant toute la guerre à
Grenoble il était pas encore rentré
en Lorraine il m'a dit on va arriver le
soir on aura qu'à accouché chez mes
parents et puis ensuite on est en partie
à faire du ski dans le
j'ai cru tomber dans ma famille c'était
comme atmosphère
on jouait des petits jeux des jeux de
cartes on joue des petits jeux c'était
très
très simple il me accueilli très
gentiment
c'était le la même atmosphère
c'est des gens qui avaient une vie
beaucoup plus facile qu'on a même eu mes
parents j'avais une des industriels qui
avait une grosse affaire de ne pas
donnonnière en Lorraine pas encore
rentré mais
c'est une affaire de famille et qui
c'est le dernier année je crois mon
beau-père en Suisse ils sont très très
vite mais
c'était les mêmes choses qui comptaient
les mêmes valeurs
et on est rentré bon on est rentré
quasiment quasiment fiancée j'ai épousé
je crois autant
c'était à tout et puis on s'est marié
on s'est marié assez au fond assez vite
et puis on est toujours marié ça va
faire soi-même 60 ans dans quelques mois
pas mal
et mes beaux-parents
ils ont été ce qui paraissait être
c'était une famille non il est de façon
beaucoup plus aisée beaucoup plus mais
c'était les mêmes choses qui comptaient
un peu plus religieux dans leur famille
un peu plus enfin c'est perdu
complètement à cette génération
mon mari avait encore sa grand-mère
maternelle
quitter une femme extraordinaire
que j'ai adoré qui m'a gâté beaucoup qui
avait beaucoup de petites filles mais je
suis devenu la petite fille privilégiée
et qui a été vraiment donc c'était des
gens très bien vraiment
très bien j'étais complètement intégré
complètement intégré dans cette famille
plus que ça
[Musique]
vos enfants j'en parle à l'occasion oui
je sais pas je
raconte pas en suivant mais on en parle
un peu plus avec le petit peut-être plus
parce que les enfants vit avec eux alors
on en parle quand il y a une occasion
il y a un de mes fils
je sais pas je dirais pas qu'il est plus
concerné je verrai simplement qu'il
parle des choses plus facilement et puis
qui est beaucoup plus juif que l'autre
on va pas s'il a épousé une femme juive
qui a des gens des portées dans sa
famille donc c'est différent
mais
les deux sont venus je fais si on
voulait venir leurs enfants aussi on en
parle enfin c'est présent oui
et maintenant de temps en temps alors
avec le petit enfant
jeune avec eux pour leur en parler
souhaite que je leur en parle
puis moi je vois alors un de mes fils il
est beaucoup de livres sur les
déportation
il travaille beaucoup avec très proche
d'Israël il a été pendant un an dans un
petit boots donc c'est assez un peu
différent
mais les deux sont très
celui qui était médecin
c'est le contraire une supportait pas il
avait dit quand nous avons été Auschwitz
façon on était plus là mais
je ne portais
et ma sœur
celle qui a été déportée Ravens n'est
jamais retourné à rabens jouet et l'idée
même d'aller aux chevilles suivantes
mais elle s'est beaucoup occupée de la
Mégane
déportés et quand nous nous voyons le
dimanche matin nous parlons toujours de
ça
les blessures ou la douleur s'apaisent
[Musique]
non je suis encore plus en colère
je suis plus en colère parce que
justement
cette banalisation m'inquiète beaucoup
cette confusion ça m'énerve je reste
trop
je reste trop meurtrisse papa par
rapport ma famille par rapport à ce que
j'ai vu par rapport à ces hongrois qui
sont arrivés dans des trains
c'est pas une question de pardon parce
que toute façon les Allemands qui sont
là maintenant c'est pas eux ils sont
pour rien
mais c'est le fait le fait c'est à nous
de le rappeler
moi j'ai longtemps dit moi sur sur mon
lit de mort
je crois que ça que je pense pas à mes
parents ni rien vous faites lui-même
bébé
un million et demi d'enfants comme ça
quand je vois mes petits-enfants
je pense à ça
je leur dis jamais naturellement
je vais citer votre maman il paraît
qu'elle a dit à la fin de sa vie
jamais le mal aux autres nous savons ce
que c'est
peut-être
non moi je souhaite jamais demain
ne souhaite pas mais
[Musique]
on n'a pas le droit d'oublier
non
on leur doit ça ceux qui sont
[Musique]
pour moi ce qui est important
de dire et de redire
c'est combien
lorsque nous étions quand pour chacune
d'entre nous
c'était important
d'espérer de penser que certaines
rentreraient et par le rêve les
témoignerait
on parle souvent du devoir de mémoire
pour ma part c'est une expression que je
n'aime pas beaucoup
c'est
un besoin par les mémoires mais en ce
qui nous concerne nous ça devoir de
transmission que nous avons parce que
nous l'avons promis toujours nos
décisions il faut qu'on sache il faut
qu'on sache comment ça s'est passé
[Musique]
Simone Veil
seul l'espoir apaise la douleur
[Musique]
un podcast original en quatre épisodes
produit par Lina
réalisée par nexom noise écrit par les
avengerstein avec le concours de
Dominique Missika
[Musique]
avec la voix d'isadoradarciale musique
originale Michael yo
[Musique]
ce podcast a été réalisé à partir du
témoignage de Simone Veil recueilli par
Catherine Bernstein le 9 mai 2006 dans
le cadre de mémoire de la Shoah une
initiative de la Fondation pour la
mémoire de la Shoah et de Lina
[Musique]
l'intégralité du récit de Simone Veil
est disponible en librairie dans seul
l'espoir apaise la douleur une coalition
Flammarion INA et en vidéo sur le site
des grands entretiens de Lina entretien
au pluriel point fr